my show as I remember it is not
necessarily a dance piece and it's not a
theater piece it's a combined piece of
theater and I don't can't say dance I I
really at this time in my life I move
yeah so and it was just true you know I
have to be honest about this the idea
has been kind of brewing for a long time
and I realized I wanted to talk about my
journey and the people the interesting
wonderful people who passed through my
life and who made me who I am from my my
parents and my my teachers and my the
people that have come into my life and
the places that changed me like of
course I grew up in Los Angeles
California I think in a really
interesting time in the 30s so that was
a difficult time for a lot of people to
live like depression babies and then
when I get to New York it was in the 50s
which was a wonderful time I think it
was really ours for me and then New
Haven which was a whole went where my
whole life changed again because by the
time I got to New York I was mainly a
dancer but when I travelled to New Haven
it became in a whole new world with the
theater the theater and the dance for me
collided because I found out I missed
that was something I was missing in the
dance world because it's really like
being in the military you it's it's very
regimented but and then at the same time
I was very fortunate that my my my
mentor
Lester Horton was anything but
regimental it was he was an incredible
combination of human being he had a
dance theater which means it was not a
studio it was a real Little Theater on
Melrose Avenue and there were you you
work with no bars and no mirrors you're
your workspace was this day
age is a small theater that had about 10
rows of seats and you had to learn to do
everything we had to help make the
costumes we had to help with the sets we
had to help change the lights and the
performance we did everything and even
afterwards you had to help clean clean
up after yourself so I taught you to be
independent and it made you think and it
kept you grounded I think you know some
kids you know where's my costume where
where is this and where no no no no no
no we didn't have that and to a person
that that worked in that theater with
Lester we've all been grateful always
been able to take care of ourselves and
I found that later in life no matter
what situation I walked into I could
size it I know how to size it up I know
what to do if I get in trouble I'll do
it myself to this day I'm still using
some of that experience so that when I
got to New York City in a joining house
of flowers which is a Broadway that was
a new experience that was a challenge as
we have the challenges at the dance
theater and then from there to go to
Yale it was oh I knew everything about
the theater itself what I had to do is
take care of the voice and being around
actors who are totally different than
dancers who are freer I I was so
fascinated by them because they had a
reason for everything that they did and
they would break down characters and and
tell stories about a character that
wasn't even in the script and I found
that fascinating so that when I went
back to the dance I thought oh why are
people turning when they're what is that
for I was questioning so that when I
went back to maybe choreographed mind
for myself or even work with somebody
I'm already thinking in terms of
character but I could always find a way
to find a reason for myself that I can
make it into something that I could feel
comfortable with if that makes any sense
you